this program is being presented to you
by the heras international winter school
on gravity and
light okay so today is is uh to try to
put the the physics and the astronomy um
uh and the science goals uh onto the
picture that I I uh talked about last
night in my public lecture and I think
most of you were at the public lecture
and uh now we're going to try to really
understand much more about what what's
going on with gravitational wave
detection and why we're doing it now the
there are two two lectures the first one
I'm calling sources of gravitational
waves I think I gave a slightly
different title about compact objects
and their gravitational waves but it's
the same subject a little bit broader
than uh just the compact objects but I
want to talk about gravitational waves
um uh generated in astronomy the gra the
waves that we want to uh
detect um from the point of view of
understanding how uh strong those waves
can be what are the what are the goals
what are the sensitivity goals for for
detectors why do we have to build
detectors that are uh as sensitive as
the ones that we're building um and also
then what kinds of information would we
get from observing gravitational waves
so I won't say in this first lecture
very much about the detectors themselves
I'll ask you to just accept that we will
have detectors that do certain kinds of
things but then in the second lecture uh
I'll go into um the techniques of of
detection the principles underlying uh
detection and uh some of the physics
challenges of building uh gravitational
wave detectors so that's the
introduction um the uh I'll start with
this quote from a book by Harry
Collins Harry um and and what what he
says is gravitational wave detection is
about seeing the biggest things that
ever
happen collisions explosions and quaking
of stars and black holes by measuring
the smallest changes that ever ever been
measured and I think that puts it in a
nutshell uh that um uh uh that contrast
uh of of looking for something that's
really important because they're big and
uh having to having to look for the for
it with something extremely difficult to
build a very sensitive um apparatus
because the changes that you're
measuring are very small now Harry
Collins is a sociologist he's not a
physicist he he gained um uh notoriety
actually in the physics Community uh at
one time by getting into a de a debate
in the pages of physics today uh with
some physicists
about is the world real are we are what
we doing as physicists real uh are we
describing the real world or is it just
something in our so so um uh for a while
he he was a person who was kind of
anathema in the physics Community um but
then he got interested in gravitational
wave from the sociology point of view we
have a big collaboration we've been
building it up from a small beginnings
of about 20 or 30 people and now we have
something like a thousand people working
worldwide on this um and he wanted to
understand as a sociologist how how it
works and so he came to us and we
concluded an agreement that he has
access to the collaboration and to all
the internal documents and he can come
to all our meetings and listen to
everything we say and then he can write
his books about how we work and he's not
supposed to dulge things that we think
are confidential um but he does uh talk
honestly about how big collaborations uh
work in physics um and um uh it's very
interesting this is first book he's got
three or four books and some some
articles so in a sense you know we're
his lab rats he comes and we're just
doing what we think is important and
he's watching what he thinks is
important um but um he's been converted
to physics he now thinks that physics is
real this is really
interesting uh the the last big
collaboration meeting um he was invited
to say say something and he said he got
up and he said I you know those
gravitational ways are out there and you
guys are going to see
them and he's such a fan uh of of of
this big collaboration and I think one
of the things that it brought home to me
about uh organizations and this is a
serious Point set aside from the rest of
my talk but but a physics collaboration
and and gravitational waves is is
one we have uh we have a a thing called
uh the LI Lio scientific collaboration
which is a voluntary
um organization of six or 700 scientists
and then there's other collaborations
that we have agreements with these are
self-governing in a way that is very
different from our political
institutions uh um the way we govern our
countries and our cities and so on is
kind of hierarchical and and um uh uh
there's a lot of competition to get up
to the top and then there's a lot of
reward and so on the the um
uh uh and there's a lot of discipline on
the in the um uh gravitational wave
collaboration like in other big physics
collaborations like particle physics is
another example we we kind of model
ourselves on particle physics
collaborations um they're very very um
they're entirely voluntary and
consensual um and so we have a
spokesperson who's elected uh
periodically and who has almost no power
who has lots of work does lots of work
to keep everything going um people come
and participate and we make we make
decisions kind kind of democratically uh
based of course on the physics not just
on Prejudice or political um uh
orientation or something like that we're
we're we we we have very clear guiding
principles but we make these decisions
collectively and and then they're
implemented by a bunch of people who do
a lot of work without any uh extra
reward and um and uh uh with and
carrying very little power it's a very
very different kind of social structure
and it's kind of amazing that it that it
holds together um uh the way it does but
I think for Harry that kind of thing is
very interesting because he he he wanted
to figure out how do we make
decisions who are the really important
people because it turns out that there
are you know there are uh there is a
hierarchy of scientific respect and so
on and if the top people say they think
this is what should happen then
generally the collaboration will do that
but it's done in a consensual way rather
than in a way that uh is enforced in
that hierarchy but anyway so the
sociology of of these big collaborations
is something that's um uh of interest to
people outside the collaborations and
Harry is a a kind of translator who's
written several books now on the history
of gravitational
waves now let's go into gravitational
waves and um the uh um
I want to go through and
highlight the most important points
about the physics of gravitation W
you've had detailed lectures about
gravitational waves and and perturbation
theory in general relativity I I want to
just highlight the things that are the
most important things for the
observational point of view the first
point of view first point to make is
that general relativity might not be
correct and therefore um well as I said
last night it's certainly not a quantum
theory so that there going to be
Corrections to it at some level and uh
it could be that those Corrections
affect gravitational waves in terms of
the speed or the polarization so those
are things you want to be alert to when
you're um making gravitational wave
observations the
information that it carries is probably
obtainable in no other way uh so we want
to we want to be able to read it um the
equivalence principle is a fundamental
principle and is is embodied in is is
Incorporated in many alternative
theories of gravity as well uh to to
general relativity and because because
the equivalence principle it it means
that gravitational waves operate by
tidal forces so if you're in free fall
there's no gravity that's what the
equivalence principle says so if a
gravitational wave comes by and you're
sitting here in free foil you don't feel
it no matter how strong the
gravitational wave is except if you're
big enough that the differential action
of the gravitational wave across your
body or across your apparatus uh is
measurable that's the tital part of the
gravitational wave so the overall sort
of local acceleration not something that
you can feel um so if you want to build
a gravitational wave detector it has to
be uh that you're looking for the
differential part of the acceleration
you're looking for uh differences in
acceleration at different
places um that means that detectors have
to be that they gain an
advantage uh by being bigger um uh
because the because you're looking for
something which to first order anyway uh
increases linearly with uh with
length
um in general relativity the speed of
gravitation waves is the speed of light
the metric uh can be described as a
perturbation on some background um and
uh that perturbation conventionally is
called H and uh it's also usually a very
small perturbation on
whatever is the effect of Newtonian uh
gravitational
potential in general relativity only two
transvers polarization modes uh and the
stretching is uh uh conventionally a
what we call H turns out to be um twice
the uh uh the title Distortion Delta L
overl um and the title Distortion is
gradient to the acceleration as as I've
just been explaining which means that in
nutonian terms it's the second gradient
the second derivative of the Newtonian
potential and that is represented in
general relativity uh by the curvature
tensor and so what we're really
measuring with gravitational waves
directly is the curvature
tensor
um the most sensitive detectors we can
we can build at the moment are
interferometers and they're linearly
polarized detectors and some all the
detectors we we build are polarized
detectors so um we talked a bit last
night in the question session about
polarization it's important to have
detectors with different orientations so
you're actually picking up different
polarization
modes now uh very simple you um I I
think these equations must be familiar
to uh there's a gauge Choice which uh we
call the transverse traceless gauge for
um uh linear perturbations of a mosy
background and uh if you go into that
gauge uh then
the uh equations without a source the
propagation equations for the
gravitational waves are very very simple
it's just the wave equation it looks
just like um uh the equations for
electromagnetic
waves um you've probably seen some some
uh picture like this this is the polariz
this is the polarization diagram this is
the action of gravitational waves if you
imagine that you have a ring of
particles that are out in outer space
they're free to move there's no uh
connections between them and then um a
gravit and a gravitational wave comes
comes in from the direction onto the
onto the plane of this picture then uh
one of the polarization act uh States
would be to distort that uh circle into
an ellipse and then because it's a wave
and it's oscillating you get an ellipse
with the same uh uh uh axes but uh with
this major and minor axes reversed and
then it goes back to being a circle so
the full one cycle of the wave takes you
that way the orthogonal polarization
because its title is actually just a 45
degree
rotation and so your your um axes go
that way and then and then it it's on
that SL with these two polarizations you
can describe any gravitational wave with
linear combination of those two
polarizations
and so now if you uh our our detector of
choice and I'm going to be talking about
detectors uh in the second lecture but
but our detector of choice today is the
interferometer and this is a simple
sketch of an interferometer where you
have light coming in from this side
through a beam s splitter uh out uh
along two different arms and if you
imagine placing the mirrors of those two
uh AR at the end points of those two
arms on this circle this is the ellipse
this is the polarization uh Circle that
I had drawn before or um if you just put
those as two two particles on that
Circle and if you put the beam splitter
right in the middle of the circle then
when the gravitational wave with the
with the top line of polarization
distorts that circle into an ellipse
what it does is it moves this mirror
further away brings this mirror in
closer and that uh automatically then
creates um a change in the interference
pattern uh at the beam splitter and the
beam splitter um uh the way that works
is is if you normalized if you've
arranged in such a way that when there's
no gravitational wave there's no light
coming out here you have complete
destructive interference then when
there's a gravitational wave you'll
you'll have light coming out here and
that'll be your signal and so you're
just reading off the intensity of the
interference coming out um and that's
proportional to the gravitational wave
signal so it's that's a simple way of
describing it and it shows that that U
interferometers are are essentially
ideal for uh detecting gravitational
waves it's exactly the kind of thing
that you want to be uh to be doing and
the history of interferometers as
gravitational wave detectors goes back
quite a long
way
um the other thing I I want to mention
and I used this term last night standard
sirens for certain kinds of
gravitational wave sources including the
most common that we expect which are
binary systems in orbit around each
other if the binary is um is shrinking
as as the hul Taylor binary Pulsar is
and as all the all the almost all the
binaries are that we're going to be
detecting certainly in the near future
um if there's a rate of change that you
can measure of the of the orbit then
that of course translates into a rate of
change of the frequency of the emitted
gravitational waves if you have that
information in the signal then you can
cons you can there's a combination of of
the things you can measure that gives
you the the distance to the uh to the
source so it's just uh a number out in
front which I won't talk about uh very
much one over the frequency squared of
the gravitational waves the chirp
time um uh uh which is the uh time scale
associated with the change rate of
change of the frequency so if you can
measure that and uh the amplitude H
which you're
measuring
um uh this uh combination has the um
remember a is a dimensionless number so
this combination has the dimensions of
distance and it's it if you're on a
cosmological scale it's the Luminosity
distance uh of uh out to the um
gravitational wave Source um there are
uh factors there are numerical factors
out here which have to do with
orientation so the gravitational waves
that you're measuring you have to make
sure you can measure their polarization
you you have to understand the
orientation of the source and everything
the number of angular things that you
have to work out before you can get the
distance since down um uh and so I've
left those out because they tend to be a
little bit complicated to look at but
this is an extremely unusual situation
in in astronomy that you can make a
measurement and and know how far away
your Source was intrinsic from intrinsic
information in the signal and that's a
calibration then of of distance ladders
we hope to tie that to the distance
ladders that are used in astronomy um uh
and uh as I said every neutron star
binary system every black hole system
that will be detected by ligo will be
coalescing and so we'll have all of
these numbers and we will be making um
distance estimates for each
Source now
um
uh I want to talk about the generation
of gravitational waves and again I'm
building on things that I'm sure that
you've seen um uh the
um excuse me the coupling of
gravitational waves to uh to distort to
to the distance changes is given by that
proportionality I left out the factor of
a half I should have put that in there
um everything on here is is actually uh
uh I'm not worrying about factors of two
I'm trying to get you to uh order of
magnitude estimates for the strengths of
gravitational waves um and H is the
amplitude now there's a thing called the
quadriple formula and I guess you've had
the quadriple formula um uh which is the
fundamental uh formula for the
generation of of amplitude of
gravitational waves in the slow motion
limit uh just as for electromagnetism
the dipole formula is is uh for charged
particles um it turns out that if you
look at the at the quadpot formula and
manipulate it a little bit um and just
try to get scalings out of it try to get
um order of magnitude estimates it turns
out to be very uh very simple the the
the quadriple formula has things in like
the density the mass density there's an
integral over the volume of the system
if I just replace the integral over the
volume time of the density if I replace
that with the mass of the system then
then uh I get some scaling some order of
magnitude estimate inside the integral
there are uh coordinates there's uh X's
uh with different indices on them um if
I just replace each one with the size R
of of the system um
excuse me the uh and I'm using capital
r as the uh dimension of the of the
radiating system then um I I can
simplify my formula and there's time
derivatives in the qu in the quadruple
formula and uh there's there um I can
replace for a self-gravitating system I
can replace time derivatives which are
basically velocities I can replace those
with uh the gravitational potential
because I have the varial theorem for
for a self-gravitating system when I do
all of those things and it's all just
order of magnitude stuff I get a very
simple formula which is that the there's
an upper limit on H which is the uh
product of just two Newtonian potentials
uh made dimensionless by scaling with
one over c squared um one is the
internal potential the mass of the
system over its own radius and the other
is the the Newtonian potential of the
system at where we are um because little
r is the distance uh from the system to
us so this is a very tiny number the
gravitational potential of the system
which is very far away at our location
and this is the internal syst number and
it's just the product of those two
Newtonian potentials is an upper limit
on age uh it's an upper limit because of
uh of considerations of symmetry you you
uh I'm sure also realize that if I had a
body that's perfectly spherical and it's
pulsating in a spherical way or
collapsing in a spherical way it doesn't
give off any gravitational waves at all
so I would still get the same scaling
for that body but I'd have zero H would
be zero so this is an upper limit which
can go all the way down to zero if I
have perfect symmetry but it's also an
upper limit that's attainable so if I if
I take a maximally asymmetric system
which is two equal mass stars in an
orbit around each other there's that's
that's a perfect quadripole
system turns out that that n that that
formula works very well that's um uh an
attainable Bound for um the uh um uh
amplitude of gravitational waves from
from a self-gravitating system so it
works only for self-gravity because I
use the varo theorem it's not working
for for Springs with masses on
them um
so but that's a very useful formula
because you can immediately plug some
numbers into it and ask yourself what
are the numbers that are appropriate for
uh targets for building gravitational
wave detectors how sensitive do I have
to be we'll do that in a minute but also
I want to point out that there's an that
gravitational waves fit in with
classical physics and if for other other
wave Fields I always talk about the
energy that's carried by waves and so on
and if you look for electromagnetism and
you write down the Energy Formula excuse
me in terms of the vector
potential or if you look for a scalar
wave and you look at the energy Flux Of
formula for in terms of the amplitude of
the scalar wave you you find that
there's always um uh it's always
proportional to the square of the time
Dera of of the amplitude of that of that
field and that's also true in general
relativity the the energy flux is
proportional to the square of the time
Dera of H um and then of course if I
know I I need that then I can then all I
have to do is put in some look at what
is the what are the fundamental
constants I need to get the dimensions
right for energy flux energy flux is is
energy per unit time per unit area so if
I put in C cubed over G you can trust me
um uh that comes out to be uh something
with those dimensions and then um I'm
almost done but then I need to know what
the factor is in front of it and that's
where all the work is that I have to
spend three days calculating on on on a
piece of paper to get the one over 32 Pi
but if I didn't care about the 1 over 32
Pi um all the rest of it is something I
can just write down
without even thinking if I believe that
general relativity fits in with all the
other classical uh field theories okay
so um I'm I'm not trying to trivialize
the 1 over 32 Pi I'm trying to point out
to you that we fit here this is a
Formula you would see in any classical
field Theory with appropriate
dimensional constants and then some
factor out in front so that's the energy
flux um the energy flux carried by a
gravitational wave and from that we can
calculate luminosities and I'm about to
do that too and and come back to this
question of how how incredibly luminous
gravitational wave sources can be in
terms of energy so let's do some simple
estimates let's talk about the amplitude
formula here if I take a mass of one and
a half solar masses that's a a typical
mass for a neutron star 1.4 or something
like that I'm not going to worry about
small differences between numbers but
I'll take a number about 1.5 solar
masses if I say oh I've reversed these
sorry if I say the the size of the
object is is 10 kilm that should be Big
R is 10 kilm um um that's a typical
radius for a neutron star um and if I
place the object far away at 100 megap
parex I mentioned that number last night
as a as a as a distance we think that
our nearest uh neutron star binary uh
coalescing during a one-year observation
might be 100 megap parex that comes from
our understanding of astronomy that uh
uh distance scale if I put all those
numbers together I get H around 10us
21 immediately tells me that's just this
formula here that immediately tells me
um where I have to go with my uh
detector sensitivity um no good having H
uh a a detector that detects h of 10us
12 which would still be a wonderful
thing to build uh this tital effects of
10 of -12 but it's not going to detect
uh interesting gravitational waves I
could do this amplitude thing for many
different kinds of sources I could uh
work it out for other other things but
typically I always wind up saying that
um I need to be around that um Supernova
used to be very important uh to the
discussion of and motivation of
gravitational wave detection and the
nearest Supernova a supernova also might
involve forming a neutron star about
that radius but the nearest Supernova is
going to be closer than this the nearest
Supernova could be a factor of a
thousand closer than this it could be
100 kilop parex which is roughly the
distance to the large maganic cloud and
the most recent Supernova nearby was in
the large M Cloud which is 50 kilop Parx
away so if I take that a factor of a
thousand away from that then I would
boost this number to 10- 18 and 10- 18
was talked about for a long time as as a
goal for gravitational wave detectors
but what it leaves out
is this upper bound it is an upper bound
but there's this geometrical Factor here
which can go right down to zero and what
we understand about Supernova explosions
now from from detailed numerical
simulations of the process is that
they're nearly spherical is that they're
they're not they're not highly
asymmetrical and so they're not coming
anywhere close to that 10us 18 and so
again we're being pushed down to 10us 21
or smaller for for nearby supern noi and
and that's the picture across the whole
spectrum of different gravitational wave
sources
okay the flux um uh the energy flux
leaving a black hole black hole merger
let's take the strongest uh
intrinsically strongest gravitational
wave thing we can uh imagine you have
two black holes they're in orbit around
each other they're about to emerge
because they're in orbit around each
other their velocities are typically the
velocities close to the speed of light
the gravitational wave Distortion is
immense the perturbation of the metric
is of order one uh um uh nearby so I'm
looking at the energy flux just outside
the system so I'm going to take H to be
of order one the time derivative um uh
will be set by the fact that the
velocities are of order the speed of
light um so that means the time
derivative is is C over the size of the
system the size is determined by the
mass uh to you know factors of two and
so I'm not going to worry about uh so um
that's the time derivative if I put
those things in in a hand waving way
again I get a number which is C 5 over
32 pi G m^2 the C 5th over
G the C the this is C cubed over G but
when you talk about the uh um uh the
flux then you you're adding in this C so
you want up C the 5th over G um is an
important number and I'll come back to
that and it's one it scales is 1 over M
squ that's the that's the energy flux um
uh that's energy per unit time per unit
area on a little sphere just surrounding
the black hole system so that's
interesting but we're not near there but
why don't we just integrate that over
the sphere and get the total Luminosity
um and uh if I do that I'm just going to
uh integrate by taking that flux number
and multiplying by the area of a sphere
of radius m of 4 Pi m^ 2 and then I get
the total energy leaving that sphere I
get the luminosity and and that gets rid
of the M squared and I get C 5th over G
with a factor of 1/8 in front of it as
well C 5th over G interesting inly is a
pure number is a pure combination of
fundamental constants it has the
dimensions of Luminosity it is energy
per unit time and um and it's a huge
number because G is Tiny and C to the
5ifth is large and so it turns out to be
10 the 52 Watts this number with the one
over8 10 of 52
Watts where does that fit on the scale
of things you know 100 watt light bulbs
or something where does that fit in
astronomy um well the Luminosity of the
sun is 4 * 10 26
Watts so this is 10 26
Suns how many stars are there in the
known universe let's do a little
calculation our galaxy contains 10 of
the 11 Stars within range of our
telescopes what we can see in observable
universe turns out there's about 10 of
the 11 galaxies so there's about 10 of
the 22 suns in the entire observable
universe and this thing is is 10 26
times the Luminosity of any one of those
Stars okay so
already this thing is is this number is
brighter than all the light being
emitted uh I mean this is in
gravitational waves this Luminosity of
the sun is in is in light but
nevertheless when you compare them just
in energy terms the energy coming out of
this thing is is far higher than the
energy coming out of all the stars in
the entire universe at that particular
time of the merger that's a pretty
astounding thing
um uh
so um the uh uh I don't know have I got
another line here
um uh another thing you might know
another thing you might compare it with
is a quazar um the most luminous um uh
objects individual objects in in the
universe are quazars there are not many
of them but there but they're but
they're as luminous as individual
galaxies so they are actually uh around
um 10 to the
um uh 37 10 of the 38 watts and um uh uh
and and all astronomers very excited by
how do you get that much luminosity and
so on but you know 10 to the 37 or 10 38
watts compared to 10 of 52 watts is
piddling it's very small so again a
gravitational W merger at the end of the
merger is is giving off an energy more
energy than anything else uh uh go than
the entire rest of the universe together
it only lasts for a tiny uh length of
time it's only during the merger which
is basically the light Crossing time
over the system so it's not uh so the
Luminosity is very high the total energy
that's given off is is is a more
reasonable amount um but anyway that's
that's those are the numbers that lead
to these astounding estimates okay so
this is what we have now in terms of
detectors that are that are operating or
or are being upgraded there are two
detectors the United States that are
called the Lio detectors they're four
kilometer interferometers one in the
state of Washington one in Louisiana
there's the Virgo detector which is uh a
3 km interferometer in uh just outside
Pisa in Italy and there's a geod
detector which is a smaller one 600
meter detector in Germany the the uh
Arrow somehow got shifted it's should be
pointing to Hanover in Germany and not
down in Switzerland somewhere so um
these three ligo the two ligo and the
Gio are for form the LSC the Lio
scientific collaboration that I
mentioned and we have uh an agreement
with Virgo which is outside the LSC but
a data sharing and Joint data analysis
agreement those are the detectors that
are uh are
operating now why are there so many
detectors and why are we cooperating in
pH physics cooperation is not the rule
at CERN if you want to detect the higs
ban you have two different detector
groups and they don't cooperate they're
you they're Rivals they they try to get
after the the higs bosan and of course
they publish their independent papers
and we as a scientific Community only
believe it if both of them get uh
consistent results on the higs boson but
they're but they're in competition with
each other um here we're not in
competition we're we we're uh jointly
analyzing our data we're pooling our
data
and uh it turns out that Lio is
upgrading now and ligo will come online
about a year before Virgo and if we get
a the gravitational way detection in
that first year the Virgo people will
still be on the paper even though their
detector isn't even operating that's
what that's the form of cooperation that
we have um uh um one of the reasons is
confidence we we have to be seeing not
just random gravitational wave signals
like the the two groups at CERN will be
seeing their own higs bosons not they're
not looking at the same higs boson
they're just making higs bosons and
seeing lots of them um uh but here we're
looking at the same gravitational wave
sources that is that arriving here and
then there and then there and so we want
to pull all that data we can't just say
oh they saw one we saw one we have to
make sure we saw the same one and that
we extract information from it we one of
that forms of information is the
polarization as I described yesterday
and Sky location um another thing is
duty cycle these detectors when we ran
them for three years a few years ago had
a duty cycle of about 80% um that means
about 20% of the time they were not in
data taking mode for uh reasons that
they're very very hard to operate
they're very it's hard to keep them
stable and so um it's very important to
have
redundancy another um another thing is
that if you get all the information you
can actually try to reduce the amount of
uh noise average over the noise of the D
detectors and try to extract a waveform
and also discrimination against glitches
this is a very important thing glitch is
a scientific term if you didn't know
that um it's a uh it's a term that means
something has gone wrong that you don't
understand uh and uh lots of things goes
wrong in these detectors that are just
suddenly something appears in the data
some pop and it can look remarkably like
a gravitational wave signal um but it's
only in one of those detectors and it's
not happening in the others and it's
very big and you know that therefore
it's come from the detector but if you
only had one detector how would you know
it was from the detector instead of from
astronomy so you have to compare the the
detectors um in what we call coincidence
mode to make sure that you're not being
fooled by
glitches um we're in uh we're in an
upgrade uh to Advanced ligo ADL is
Advanced ligo right now there's an
advanced Virgo as well but this is the
slide for advanced ligo this is a
sensitivity diagram I I we'll talk more
about diagrams like this in my second
lecture but you see numbers here of
strain um uh 10us 23 10- 22 these are
measures of H um and um here are the
frequency band from 10 Herz to 100 Herz
to 1,00 this is the main frequency
observing band for for loo and so these
are basically plots of the noise um the
the lower down these curves get the more
sensitive the detector because the lower
the noise and um uh what we expect uh
maybe 2015 this slide is a couple years
old but we're on schedule so we we're
hoping to turn on the first detectors uh
perhaps by the by the end of this year
um we might have a sensitivity uh that's
a bit like this it'll be factors of
maybe three or four better than uh we we
operated with before and it might be
enough to make a first detection we
don't know we be able to see binary
neutron stars two neutron stars
spiraling together 60 megap parex away
the Virgo cluster galaxies to just
normalize things is 20 megap parex away
and contains a couple of thousand
galaxies out to 60 megap parex you're a
factor of three further out and
therefore a factor of about 30 more in
volume so instead of a couple of
thousand uh galaxies you have uh maybe
60,000 maybe 100,000 galaxies we think
that there's one binary neutron star
spiral uh per year per
Galaxy uh sorry one binary neutron star
in spiral per Galaxy every 10 of the
five years we think it happens in our
galaxy every time five years in a
typical Galaxy so if you get out to
100,000 galaxies you have a chance that
you're going to see one a year and and
so there is a chance that at at 60 megap
Parx we might be able to detect one um
but that's just an intermediate step uh
um and uh by let that that blue curve
then
becomes um this is extended by this
brown
curve excuse me maybe in a couple of
years uh the laser light is the same but
we're we're improving the the low
frequency performance and we've
increased our binary neutron star range
to 140 megap Parx and at that
point those of us who study the
astrophysics are are convinced that that
we have enough range to be detecting a
few of these events per year
so um sometime between the end of this
year and 2017 we should be expecting the
first detections then later on this this
we can modify the shape and we can do
lots of Tricks but that's the upgrade
path that we're on right
now uh we're also doing um uh a lot of
work on on the detection uh algorithms
the the data analysis and I do want to
emphasize this even though I'm not going
to put too much time into it
gravitational wave detection
uh the data analysis is crucial
component of course any experiment you
have to analyze your data but um all the
signals that we're seeing all the
signals we expect to receive these
binary neutrons star signals if you look
at the raw data coming off the detector
you won't see them they're down below
the Noise by factors of five or 10 they
have to be pulled out by um uh
intelligent uh filtering based upon a
prior knowledge of what that signal is
going going to look like without doing
um filtering you're not going to be able
to detect a gravitational wave at all
and so the data analysis is a crucial
step and and when the data analysis
people the computer geeks and the SC
theoretical physicists when they improve
their their ability to pull signals out
of Noise by a factor of two let's say
that improves the range of the Detector
by a factor of two that improves the
volume of detection by a factor of eight
that's like putting in a couple of
million
to to to uh upgrade the sensitivity of
the detector so the the the effort that
goes into Data analysis is probably
involves more than half of the people in
this collaboration and it's a crucial
part of understanding um of of of the
detection so we've done a lot uh we
we've written lots of papers on our
methods and our methods are generally
applicable that we've developed for
digging deep in the noise they generally
applicable other areas of astronomy and
so other astronomers have been giving us
data uh and we for instance have
discovered in gamar data we've
discovered Gamay pulsars um and uh uh
another Gamay Pulsar here uh that's uh
the person leading this activity is is
uh uh Bruce Allen he's one of the
directors of the Albert Einstein
Institute in in Hanover um and uh uh so
and we're also finding and Radio Data
we've we've uh identified a number of
new radio
pulsars just because we have techniques
that can get into the noise in anybody's
data better than uh what people have
done
before our searches have been very slow
it's taken us a long time to validate
everything the the code is validated
line by line with internal reviews you
write a code you you say you detected
something another committee is formed
within the collaboration they go through
your code line by line you have tojust
ify everything and then you have to
prove that you tested it with fake
injections into Data unrealistic data
and so on there's a huge amount of
approval process validation before
anything gets released and that is a
slow process so one of the things we're
doing right now is to make it faster and
um uh we want to be able to give out
alerts that are within a minute let's
say uh um that maybe don't have all
those checks in them but but but
everything's been validated ahead of
time so that when when we get an alert
we're reasonably sure it'll be right um
and and we give those alerts out to
astronomers and then they can uh see if
they can find something else in the sky
that might validate um uh the existence
of a real
event so we we are going to be we're uh
initially the data is private but after
the first detection we're going to have
public releases our earlier data is now
public uh you can go and uh see if we
missed any gravitational waves in in the
data we had uh back in 2005 to 2010 10
um and uh so there's there's uh a lot of
stuff here but um we uh uh plan
eventually to to just putting all the
data out
immediately um and we have
collaborations with uh a number of of uh
uh collaborations you might uh you might
have heard about all of which are are
able to detect transient events and
therefore uh might might be able to say
see things that are are are happening in
coincidence with our gravitational wave
signals and um uh we now have about 40
uh collaborations withus for um sharing
data and and looking at these um uh
collaborate looking at these things and
so uh this say a lot of activity in
building up multimessenger
astronomy uh now I talked about locating
the sources um I I don't want to uh
spend too much um we talked about that
with the demonstration and so on last
night um it depends the short birst was
what our demonstration was talking about
you know the clapping and so on um loc
those you localize that with time delays
among detectors and basically with two
detectors you can't you can't do and it
what you get is a circle on the sky with
just two detectors with three detectors
you can get a good position but even so
um the positions are um
uh are are rather large uh the aab box
is rather large 10 square degrees uh
might be a good Arab box so uh there's a
premium Now astronomers like building
telescopes that Focus down to you know a
few arc minutes or something like that
and and that they're not happy if you
tell them look for something in 10
square degrees um but there are now
they're building Widefield telescopes
and uh survey telescopes and they're
covering the whole Sky every every few
nights and so on so so uh there are a
lot of astronomers who can actually look
in a ton Square degree uh field of view
and um uh and hope to find something um
another thing is the pulsars I didn't
talk about localizing GW pulsars
gravitational way pulsars but that's a
different story that's something where
you use the Doppler effect that I talked
about with Lisa last night as the Earth
is RO going around the Sun the the the
uh you get an imposed uh phase modul on
on a continuous signal from uh a pulsar
and that really can give you a good
location in fact it's exactly how radio
astronomers get locations of pulsars and
we have the same sort of Errors so down
to an arc second you can loc localize
pulsars with gravitational waves so it's
very different depending on the source
of gravitational waves what the
localization is going to
be now this year uh later on we're going
to come in with um these uh uh big
interferometers uh the two Hanford and
uh the Hanford the Livingston the
Hanford Livingston and the Virgo
detectors Gio is not going to be part of
this observing Network because it's it's
um uh on too short of
Baseline GI was able to participate
earlier because it had more
sophisticated Technologies but those
Technologies were developed with the aim
of putting them into these detectors in
the upgrade so now when these detectors
have the have those sophisticated
Technologies Geo is Left Behind because
of its shorter Baseline uh so basically
we'll have three detectors which is the
minimum that we're that we need for
direction finding
um uh the baselines um oops I'm sorry
the baselines are um 27 milliseconds
largest Baseline resolving power of a
telescope depends upon the ratio of the
wavelength to the size of the of the
telescope this is this this is the size
of the telescope basically and the
wavelength is actually um uh uh
comparable or even larger and so the
resolving power is is uh uh is weak and
that's why we're not getting very good
positions on the
sky um what are we going so I what we
did with the first uh inter perometer
observations was set upper limits we we
didn't find any big surprises we've been
able to set uh upper limits on the on
the rates of things and predict what the
what the uh rates might be in in uh the
next generation of detectors um I just
put up this diagram you'll see some more
of these later on this is a antenna
diagram uh of a of a detector so a
detector that's flat here in the XY
plane of this diagram um this is the
sensitivity of the detector the
interferometer to gravitational waves
averaged over polarization um in
different directions and you see it's
most sensitive up up the Axis so if you
have a detector that's on the ground
here a gravitational wave Source
directly above
that's or below that's the most
sensitive
directions and there are some directions
where the sensitivity goes to zero
that's where your uh wave is coming in
at 45 degrees to your two two arms
because because that's the PO that's uh
um a wave that will influence both arms
essentially the same way that's just the
wrong polarization State and so uh
you'll get zero sensitivity so that's
where these holes are in this in this
what we call a peanut diagram um
uh but but uh the sensitivity is apart
from those holes the sensitivity varies
by factors of two or three over the
sky um
oops this is the sensitivity of uh the
henford and Livingstone the two Lio
detectors together when you put them
together um and imagine now they're
locate this there's an orientation here
they're located in the United States
imagine you're you're somewhere over the
North Atlantic Ocean okay and you're
looking down this is the the sensitivity
diagram so there so there's a clear axis
where there's the most sensitive uh
detections and this is um with um Virgo
added in and it becomes a bit more
symmetrical uh so we're getting better
Sky coverage that's the sensitivity of
those uh of that
Network now I would mainly want to talk
about um uh the gravitational wave
sources and so neutron star emerges I
mention many times um there what what
are we going to learn when we have
neutron star merges first of all um uh
we know that there are a number of
systems uh in our own Galaxy we we know
seven systems in our own Galaxy that are
already on the way to merger and have
merger times in the range merger
remaining lifetimes in the range up to
about 10 of the eight years um we can
only see a small fraction of our own
Galaxy these are discovered by radio uh
observations and you may or may not
realize that radio telescopes
particularly looking for
pulsars they only see the near part of
our galaxy they don't even see as far as
the gala galactic center and they don't
see the other side of the Galaxy at all
so we only have a small sample of the
number that are in our galaxy um and but
it's on the basis of that sample that
and the selection effects in radio
observations that the radio astronomers
calculate that they're probably enough
systems in our galaxy that the one
that's closest to merger is about 10 of
the five years away that's that number
of 10 of the five years once every 10 of
five years per
Galaxy um so so there are a lot of these
systems around and if if you can uh have
enough sensitivity to measure one one or
two uh per year what are you going to
learn well you're going to learn a lot
about the equation of state of neutron
stars uh hot neutron stars particularly
as they merge together they get very hot
and it's a new form of nuclear matter
that you cannot duplicate in the um in
the lab so uh there are lots of
different calculations of what that
might be like we want to actually
understand the Nuclear Physics um so
we'll be observing that and and that'll
affect the gravitational waves that they
emit um you will uh understand also um
the mass distribution of neutron stars
and binaries there's a very mysterious
thing which is that most binaries that
we know with a with a pulsar in them the
Pulsar is around uh 1.4 solar masses and
that's uh a mysterious thing because we
believe that you can make pulsars up to
two in fact we there are some pulsars
that are there are some pulsars that are
known with with masses up to about two
Cellar masses but somehow in these
binary systems they tend to be smaller
and so we would like to understand that
um uh and uh um binary black and we
might also have have merges of black
holes instead of binary neutron stars
and then that's a very good test of
strong field generation relativity and
we would For the First Time begin to
understand what the distribution of
masses and so on is for real black holes
we don't have any observations
that um there's a good reason to believe
that neutron star merges produce a short
Gamay burst and um that's something that
the uh Gamay astronomers are are uh
believe and so they're very interested
in the gravitational wave observations
that could be in coincidence with their
bursts but G bursts are beamed Gamay
come out in a beam and the fraction of
the sky covered by that beam is probably
only 1% maybe 3% but that means that
something like one out of 30 or one out
of a 100 gravitational wave events will
be accompanied by a Gamay burst that
will be visible to the Gamay detectors
and so it's not going to be an easy
thing to make this
correlation uh so we the the first
Network when we get under with with with
our full event rate we might be getting
a one per year uh in coincidence with
Gamay bursts um but we also are going to
have some very strong signals our our
threshold for signal to noise is going
to be around 12 signal noise is
amplitude signal noise and and so uh an
amplitude signal noise of
12 uh if you compare that with a with an
optical observation of a signal noise
that's an energy based uh Photon
counting observation you square it so 12
a signal is 12 for us is is about 150 um
uh um uh C noise for optical astronomers
which isn't a bad signal noise they're
often dealing with much worse signal
noise than that um so it's a respectable
signal noise but if you're getting a
let's say 30 events per year when we
finally develop our detector Network
fully um then some of those are going to
be
stronger and uh the strongest ones are
are going to produce uh um uh even more
science the uh strongest event might
have a signal no of 27 let's say
30 have a smaller error box we'll be
able to pin it down
better and um uh uh and and we'll get a
a better detector a better distance and
so on we'll be able to identify uh the
counterpart uh we'll get a red shift and
uh and so on so that'll that'll help
with our calibration that'll help with
the uh um the cosmology that we want to
do and so on so there's a lot of there's
a lot of stuff coming out of neutron
stars this is a picture uh of from the
endpoint of a numerical simulation done
by luchiano Rola at the Albert Einstein
Institute Rola is now at the University
of Frankfurt um uh and still doing very
interesting simulations of of neutron
star merges with in full general
relativity with um full hydrodynamics
Magneto hydrodynamics and this is the
magnetic field structure at the end of
that simulation it was a chaotic
magnetic field carried in by two neutron
stars with their own magnetic fields it
was stirred up but when those two mag
when those two neutron stars merged they
eventually formed a black hole once that
black hole formed this magnetic field
became very ordered and and you have
this polar magnetic field remarkably
coming out like this it wasn't put in by
hand and that's where we think the Jets
the Gamay Jets come from we think the
Gamay are channeled by these magnetic
field lines into this sort of 1% or 3%
of the sky
this network is going to be expanded um
and we will be uh bringing in um uh
um uh two more detectors uh so here the
original uh uh four but we're going to
be so already in Japan they're building
kagra kagra is short is a clever name
kagra is has has a meaning in Japanese
itself but it also short for Coca Ka
gravitational wave detector gr um camea
if you remember is where the the
Japanese have this wonderful nutrino uh
detector it's in a mountain um uh inside
some tunnels in a mountain well in that
same Mountain they've dug two 3
kilometer tunnels and they're putting in
the gravitational wave detector and
that's very quiet seismically quiet to
be underground in a mountain it's a a
good location they have uh a very
ambitious detector they're also going to
be uh cry cooling it cryogenically which
we don't do with the other ones to
reduce the thermal noise effects so
that's a that's an interesting uh
project and it's already started they've
got their tunnels and they've got their
vacuum system um ligo India is is still
waiting final
approval but we expect it to be approved
India had an election and then they were
looked up their science budget again but
it's a cooperation with a close
cooperation with ligo ligo originally
planned to put two detectors in the
Washington Hanford Washington vacuum
system two independent detectors but
then it was realized that if you could
put the that one of those detectors
somewhere else in the world you get the
benefits of Baseline Direction finding
coincidence there all of those things
are improved and so originally it was
offered to Australia and they said no
they would rather build the ska this
square kilometer array and they um uh
didn't allocate enough money to build
the gravitational wave detector but then
India uh came in and said uh we would
like to host uh that Lio detector so the
deal is that India builds the vacuum
system and all the civil engineering and
ligo takes all the components that are
identical to the components that are in
these two Lio detectors and installs it
in that vacuum system in India and we
have a Lio detector in India so that's
what's the plan is we're waiting for
final approval for that but when we have
these five uh um uh full detectors we
have a lot more information about
uh gravitational waves um we expect that
um uh that that the rest of this decade
will be just the three big detectors um
we're hoping Liu window will this is a
little optimistic now I think the delays
in funding will will push it back past
2020 kagra has a has a Target around
2020 and it's going to be difficult to
meet that but it it may it may get there
um but by 2025 we will have um uh five
full sensitivity detectors and that's uh
that's going to be um much better for
things like Direction finding here's the
same map but it turns out the best
Baseline is is this one between
Louisiana and India you would you don't
see it when you draw a map flat like
that you might think Japan is further
away but actually going through the
Earth as these baselines do because
gravitational waves go through the Earth
um this is the longest Baseline in in
that
Network and so that that's already an
improvement of of 30 or 40% in Direction
finding and uh the the fact that you
have several detectors and so on gives
you even better uh information about
polarization and
directions uh so when when India and
Japan come in we're going to have much
uh uh better volume that that antenna
pattern that I showed you will get more
and more spherical so we'll we'll be
covering the whole sky with rough
roughly roughly the same sensitivity and
reach uh we'll have have uh duty cycle
will be much improved because if a
detector goes down there'll still be
four detectors operating um so we won't
be missing events uh we'll get better
pointing we'll have um better
discrimination against these glitches so
we would expect two or three times as
many uh events um uh maybe four as we
approve our data analysis improv in more
more more uh putting more um
sophisticated data analysis techniques
that are that are possible with with
when you have more detectors uh this is
that diagram I showed you before with
the present
system but when we have the mo it's much
more
symmetrical uh so we might get 100 to
200 events uh per year and uh with um uh
neutron
stars uh um what that means is that the
strongest event now is going to have a
signal to noise of 60 and so the the the
information you get from really about
the neutron star equation of state and
so on from these very strong events will
be um uh uh will be much improved and we
would have a number of gamma rayst
coincidences and then we'll be able to
start testing the cosmology we'll be
able to measure the Hubble constant to
uh accuracies of a percent or so um and
uh all that's as accurate as the uh
astronomers are able to do it right now
and so uh it's going to be very
interesting interesting to see if we can
get a Hubble constant value which is the
same as the uh Optical astronomy ladder
um gamr bursts uh uh uh has a lot of um
uh interest and and so we'll be we'll be
filling in a lot of details on that
black holes are to me the most
interesting things because we don't see
them in any other way particularly black
hole mergers and we we we don't even
know how to estimate the numbers um that
we we've tried to be rather
conservative um uh our range for black
holes is bigger much we see them much
further away because they're much more
massive but we um uh but but the volume
rate is probably lower we're kind of
expecting that the rate in our detectors
for detecting them is going to be
comparable to the neutron star rate
maybe a half of the neutron star rate
but there are astronomers saying no that
there are a lot more black hole binaries
out there than than the more
conservative estimates we've used so it
could be that our data will be will be
dominated by black hole mergers it just
depends upon what's happening in nature
and we really don't understand the black
hole binary formation well at
all but on the basis of these rather
conservative estimates we expect to see
them out to fairly large red shifts May
almost red shifts of order one and um uh
uh for the first time got a census of um
of black holes and binary black holes
and their spins and so on we have very
accurate numerical simulations now at
black hole merges we can really uh
compare uh them with general relativity
and um uh test uh uh test the model of
general relativity test things like
Cosmic censorship in general relativity
have you mentioned Cosmic sensorship
yeah it's a it's a conjecture it's uh we
believe that general relativity leads to
no netive singularities but we don't
know that that's not a theorem in
general relativity um so uh when you're
how you know when you're forming merges
of black holes do you get uh a black
hole with a nice horizon or do you get
something weird that's something you can
test with gravitational wave of
observations and again Hubble constant
so um there's a lot more that'll come
out I haven't said much about
gravitation wave pulsars very difficult
to to detect because they're very weak
they're not they're not whole Stars
they're little lumps on stars that are
that are
radiating so we only expect them from
rather near bu systems probably in our
own Galaxy
um uh but also uh to build up signal you
have to you have to coherently integrate
for for months during which time there's
a huge phase modulation imprinted on the
signal so it's not simple to just
coherently integrate over months and so
there's so the the search for
gravitational wave pulsars dominates our
Computing
requirements um and uh in fact um uh uh
uh we we we don't do it optimally even
though we know how to do it optimally
because we can't put together enough
computer power um so we have upper
limits now from um
uh uh earlier observations that are that
are interesting um uh from an
astronomical point of view but we have
no detections yet uh there as a one of
the one of one way of saying how how
difficult it is you have to do your uh
full uh search over all frequencies for
each one different of 10 of the 10
different Sky locations um and that's an
indication of the Computing requirement
um we do suboptimal searches and much of
this is done in Einstein at home do you
know about Einstein at
home ah well copy this down and and put
it into Google and go and help us
Einstein at home is a screen saver you
there are times I know when you're not
looking at your computer screens right
not all you know you're asleep sometimes
um uh and so let your computer run with
a screen saver that we give you and
behind the screen saver we're doing our
data analysis on your computer we
download some data onto your computer uh
we we look for pulsars it's part of the
Pulsar search uh thing is the main thing
and then if it finds some candidates it
sends um the data back to to our big
computers and we assemble this from from
lots of different uh people around the
world who are doing this and um uh it
gives a lot of computing
power um right now we have uh uh tens of
thousands of participants uh tens of
thousands of computers and we're uh
we're getting more than
um
uh we're getting close to a petaflop of
computing donated to us by all these
people hundreds of hundreds of teraflops
um uh that's an astounding amount of
computing which we could never buy uh
and so when I ask you to do it I'm I'm
asking you to join a big project it's
not some trivial sort of sideline this
is how we we look for post arts and um
um
the uh main benefit to us is not just
that we couldn't buy that many
processors is that we couldn't pay for
the
electricity so so when I when I say
leave your computer on overnight you're
paying for the
electricity uh uh okay so but uh that's
that's the economics of computing these
days and and again that's run by Bruce
Allen at the Albert Einstein Institute
in Hanover
um uh so please go to look at Einstein
at home and download it and uh
contribute and and it's a community we
have we put out I told you about the
Gamay pulsars and the radio pulsars that
we discovered we put those out on
Einstein at home that's how we found
them and so there are people in Germany
there are ordinary people who you know
accountants who join this thing and they
let the thing run on their computers and
they get a they get an email that says
you have found you participated in the
discovery of this Gamay PSAR and we want
redundancy so we don't trust any one
person's computer maybe they've you know
done something to it um so we get
redundancy so maybe we have three people
participating in this and they get their
names on the website and sometimes the
newspapers pick it up it's really
actually very interesting uh citizen
science um so that's Einstein at home
uh the the um I I haven't I want to
round up uh lots of uh other sources I
don't I
um uh have a few more slides to get
through uh Supernova as I said earlier
was once the primary motivation for
early detect early attempts to detect
gravitational waves based upon this
number of 10 of minus 18 we saw how we
got the number of 10 of - 18 but now we
believe it's much much uh the goal
should be uh uh 10us 1 or 10us 22 and uh
so it may be that if we when we when our
detector is running if there's a
supernova in our galaxy that we will
actually detect the gravitational waves
from it but not from distant galaxies um
but if we do it'll be in coincidence
with the nutrino detectors that that are
running now uh and and so we'll have a
very clear coincidence signal be very
interesting for for all the physics um
it's hard to predict the waveforms it's
a very chaotic event and so we're going
to learn a lot if we can do it uh but
it's it's a difficult observation to
make
uh now the we talked a bit about last
night the stochastic background the the
primordial background of gravitational
waves from The Big Bang and I mentioned
cosmic strings there's there's ample
opportunity in these places if we can
observe these uh kinds of events to to
pull out some new physics um two ligo
detectors the way you detect a CO a
background a CO
a random background of gravitational
waves from The Big Bang that hiss that I
played um if you have only one detector
then then it has to be a louder hiss
than the hiss of noise from your
detector and you have to have a lot of
confidence in this and if you know the
story about the discovery of the cosmic
microwave background that's exactly how
the cosmic microwave background was
discovered by penus and Wilson they had
a radio telescope and they had a hiss
and and and no matter where they put
pointed the telescope they kept getting
the same hiss and uh
and they believed their telescope was
better than that they believed their
radio receiver was quieter than that so
um uh eventually you know they they
realized that they were seeing a cosmic
uh microwave background um we would
rather be in a position where we can go
deeper than the noise of our detectors
and the way you do that is to
cross-correlate so if you have two
detectors that are getting the same his
from cosmology but they have
uncorrelated noise then you then you
multiply those two data streams and
integrate and the uncorrelated noise is
suppressed uh relative to the correlated
uh signal and so we think we can get
down to around 10us 9 of closure density
if the gravitational wave background has
an energy density that's 10us 9 of the
uh uh average energy density of the
universe then uh we think we could
detect it how do what does that number
mean the cosmic microwave background is
around 10us 5
okay so we're talking about an energy
density that's 10us four of the cosmic
micro background but that's quite a
large density compared to the
predictions the predictions are that it
should be around 10us 15 okay so uh so
we don't have a lot of optimism that
we're going to detect something if we
detect something then that's great
that's new
physics
um uh yeah so
um now we're going to be building third
generation detectors and uh um uh those
are uh we we hope anyway after our first
detections we're going to go into go
back to the funding agencies that have
been so generous with their money and
say um well we've proved that we can do
this but we can only see a small
fraction of the universe out to 100
megap parex or 200 megap parex 300 megap
parex but that's only uh uh a red shifts
of less than 0.1 we want to see the
whole universe so we want a 10 times
better
sensitivity um and that's uh uh um uh we
have a detailed study already in Europe
that was funded by the European Union
for the Einstein
telescope and um that will go
underground like they're doing in Japan
that will be cryogenic like they're
doing in Japan uh it'll have much higher
laser power than they're using in
Japan it'll cancel out local Newtonian
noise I do you remember in the film
yesterday I showed this weather pattern
and I said this remarkable thing that at
on time scales of about an hour
the the disturbances in gravity of
weather are larger than the
gravitational wave disturbances we
expect from astronomy well even at let's
say on at one Hertz let's say time
scales of a second if you're uh if you
got a detector on the ground you begin
to have problems with Newtonian noise
that is if there's a seismic wave that
runs underneath runs through the Rocks
um it's a compression Wave It's a
density wave in the rocks it changes
gravity locally and that gravity CH
those gravity changes on on the right
time scales time scales of a second or
so are larger than we would expect and
so we'd have to measure them and remove
them we'd have to have seismic
monitoring and and all sorts of things
and actually remove those neonian noise
that Newtonian noise from the data and
and or cancel it out in some other way
and that's Again part of this Einstein
project it's a very sophisticated uh way
of extending the frequency range to
lower lower frequencies um and squeezed
light which I'll talk about this
afternoon I mean in in the next lecture
um it's included uh in an U EU priority
list called The Magnificent 7 of astrop
particle physics projects but
um uh you can make all the lists you
want but at the end you still have to
get the money and uh we will we're not
going to seriously try to do that until
after our first detections with with
detectors but this is a picture that I
briefly showed last night
of of of down here a couple hundred
meters deep 10 km long tunnels with
three observing uh stations here and you
can get into them with um uh elevators
and it's very very uh elaborate
engineering it's an expensive it's a 1
billion Euro
project uh so the third so that would
only be justified if you uh had um uh
good science the that and so if you're
going to spend that much money you might
as well get everything you that's out
there and that this that system would
detect every neutron star binary
coalesence that happens anywhere in the
universe during the time of observation
uh and that's a huge population of
neutron star mergers and there's a very
rich um uh set of information we would
also monitor all the black holes out to
Regus of 15 now Regus of 15 are very
early in the universe we don't know when
the first black hole mergers were were
began to happen but basically what we're
saying is we would we would start we
would see the onset of ordinary black
hole mergers and stuff like that
um so uh uh well I want to skip I want
to say a few more things so let's skip
over that because I do want uh how I
should be stopping about now is that
right 15 more minutes 15 oh yeah oh then
that that'll be enough uh this I only
have a couple more slides uh I want to I
want talk about the sources for Lisa the
space-based um uh uh things and a little
bit about what's happening uh for Lisa
un Leisa Pathfinder um if you remember
from what I said last night we're we're
we're the from space we're looking at
the lower frequency range that's totally
masked by gravity disturbances on Earth
so we have to get away so we're talking
about
millerz time scales of an
hour um and um uh
uh again uh black holes figure black
hole binaries figures uh uh a lot in
that but if you look at what the what
the time scale is what the the one hour
time scale is basically a black hole
with a light Crossing time of an hour
means a radius of one light hour and a
mass turns out around 10 of the five 10
of the six solar masses so so the
natural radiators for black hole
binaries in the Lisa band are massive
black holes of a million solar masses it
just
happens that our
galaxy has at the center of it a black
hole of around four million solar masses
it happens that all galaxies seem to
have massive black holes in in their
centers and there's a spectrum masses
but the typical masses of the galaxies
we've been able to to to determine
masses for are of the order of a million
Cellar masses so it happens that the
Lisa band is perfect for exploring the
Dynamics of the black holes that that
are crucial part of the formation of
galaxies that reside at Center of every
um every ordinary Galaxy and galaxies
merge uh together uh and um the the
black holes are then brought into merger
and you get these binaries so we think
there's a reasonable population that we
should be going for going after and and
Lisa would be seeing
these Lisa would also be sensitive to
white dwarf binaries in our own galaxies
binaries of white dwarfs white dwarfs
are smaller masses than neutron stars
and they the binaries we're talking
about have 1 hour periods rather than
the one minute periods or or less of the
cesing neutron stars that we talked
about so there's lots and lots of system
we don't have to go to 100 megap parex
they're all our galaxy is full of
systems with Neutron with with white
dwarfs that have one hour periods and uh
there's so many that there would be a
confusion noise in the Lea Lea data
there'd be uh at at the longer per
periods there'd be so many would it
actually would limit the sensitivity of
the mission but um at higher frequencies
you could see them individually you
could separate them out individually all
over the sky from the modulation effects
that that you get and um uh and and so
the astronomer is very very interested
in the in the formation of white dwarf
binaries it's a pathway of Stellar
Evolution to try to understand how Stars
evolve and die um and so we'll be giving
them a huge amount a huge data base of
those um and then there's a capture of
small black holes by Massive ones I
played you the the uh very dissonant
kind of music that comes from such a a
capture um the technology for detecting
gravitational waves in space is
different from on the ground um uh we'll
talk about the the Technologies later on
but um but uh it involves creating um uh
regions in space where where you exclude
all disturbances you want something that
is pure equivalence principle you want
to have locations in space where it's
just the equos principle and nothing
else no forces from outside and we do
that by by flying inside our
spacecraft a cube of metal uh gold
Platinum uh and it's free inside it's in
a housing but it's but it's not in
contact with anything else and it's the
reference point for o an trometry then
that we build a spacecraft around this
Cube and the job the of the spacecraft
is not to bump into the cube okay so
there's a force on the spacecraft all
the time there's pressure from the Sun
there's all sorts of things happening um
uh but um the the the the spacecraft is
constantly looking at where the cube is
and has little micro thrusters that it
it fires when it's being pushed toward
the cube and and and comes away again
okay so that's the that's the idea of of
of our interferometry every one of these
spacecrafts has uh well every and every
arm of the ineter is terminated by two
Cube Cube at each
end and um uh you have to uh put these
things in space well you you have to
clamp the cube down to get it into
through the rocket ride to get it up
there and then you have to release it
and all sorts of Technologies there's
things you cannot test on the ground and
so Issa decided it would build at least
a Pathfinder spacecraft and put up um
one arm of an inter prometer but only
with a with an arm length of half a
meter so there's a cube here there's a
cube here all both within the same
spacecraft and we do the interferometry
between them there's not a the arm
length isn't big enough to detect
gravitational waves it's just a test of
the technology um and this has been this
has been a very instructive thing we've
had we've been let down by European
industry so often because they've never
built anything like this and they would
bid for a contract to build it and oh
yeah we'll build it and then they don't
build it um so it's been an incredibly
uh rough ride to get this thing working
but it has been built it's now a in the
final stages of assembly and late this
year it'll be launched by Issa from its
PL its Spaceport in Kuru in South
America by a Vega launcher and it'll go
out to the L1 lrange point to the Earth
Moon system and sit there for about 6
months and just do lots and lots of
experiments to about to validate all the
Technologies um so we're very excited by
that that'll be the gatekeeper for uh
the rest of uh uh the Lisa project and I
said right now we're number three on the
on the list we're hoping that if Lisa
Pathfinder performs the way we expect it
to perform that we have a very strong
argument for coming earlier and getting
an earlier launch but we'll see um uh
basically um I I I'm gonna forget that
Lisa Pathfinder has lots of um uh uh
very sophisticated
equipment um uh this is the test MK that
gold Platinum Cube you can see the
corners here which which are where the
clamps hold it and have to have to
release it then little uh indentations
and it's inside an El it sits inside
this electrod housing which capacitively
senses the position you're not never
supposed to come in contact with the
sides of the electrode housing um and
then the whole thing is is in inside
vacuum chamber inside uh all of this and
so there's a lot of very sophisticated
things that are being built in Italy at
uh trento University in uh at the AI in
Hanover at astrium uh in um uh uh
Frick's hoffen so there's lots of um uh
contributors to this
project
um you you will see the acronym Lisa and
the Elisa they're they're we're using
them almost interchangeably Lisa was was
the original uh project which was this
triangle thing that I that I showed you
in the film last night the European
Space Agency decided it couldn't afford
to do that on its own it wanted a
descoped project and so we gave them a
project with just two of those three
arms uh still has three spacecraft you
have to have three spacecraft um and
we've called that Elisa and so that's a
kind of Base minimum Baseline but uh
that East is going forward with now but
but the idea is we will bring in other
partners uh China perhaps uh the USA
almost certainly and get back enough
money to get that third arm um so
there's a lot of politics and a lot of
strategy here but I will be talking
mostly about Lisa because the goal is uh
of of the community is to get a three
armed uh detector into space like
Lisa uh if you want to know more there's
a lot of stuff on the web we even have
our own uh website Elisa science.org um
where you can keep up with the latest
developments including L Lisa
Pathfinder um now black holes are the
main targets uh of Lisa and Elisa and so
this is a sensitivity diagram for the
only the two Arm System and I want to
show you something remarkable about the
sensitivity to black holes and this is
what sells the project most to the
astronomers um what I've got here is uh
a diagram of massive black hole system
I'm assuming we're going to have we're
going to have a with two equal Mass
black holes and um merging together and
here's a red shift at which you might
see them red shifts up to
20 put things into perspective around
here the universe was reionized so this
is very early times and then there was a
burst of UV radiation from early star
formation and around here the universe
was reionized it's very hard for
astronomers to see through that ion uh
screen and get Optical or radio
observations back to the
uh very early epics but at it's at these
very early epics that all the really
interesting stuff about structure
formation was happening the little
clumps of gas coming together form
little fragments that then merge
together form bigger fragments and merge
together ultimately to form galaxies all
of that was going on through this whole
period of time all right so um and and
along with the structure formation were
black holes that were being formed
because that's how the black hole in the
center of our galaxy got there it was
mer if formed by a merger among uh
smaller black holes that were formed in
the centers of smaller fragments and so
on uh whoops
oh I press the
wrong I have pressed the wrong button
and
now I don't know how to get
back uh let's try this
again oh okay
um all
right the advanced ligo uh and and
groundbased detectors they'll they'll
explore this corner of the diagram out
to Red shifts not quite equal to one and
with masses maybe 10 of the two 10 of
the
2.5 um that's those are the first black
holes we'll see with gravitational wave
detectors um uh the Einstein telescope
that I talked about the Next Generation
that'll fill in um a bigger range it'll
go out to R just around two for black
holes and up to almost 10 the four solar
masses
um astronomers Optical astronomers uh
and so on will uh also very interested
in black holes they go for the other end
it's much easier for them to see the 10
of the 10 solar mass black holes in
quazars um and then
um uh that uh uh uh it becomes harder
and harder as the mass goes down so they
can see those out to high red shifts but
then but then um as for lower masses
they can see only to the near nearest
part of the universe
um we're going to be uh uh doing Pulsar
timing and uh for gravitational waves um
which is uh a way of detecting
gravitational waves with pulsars and
that only is the most massive black
holes up here 10 of the 8 to 10 of the
10 solar masses and that goes out to Red
shifts of two so that's sort of
comparable to ET that's where those
are this is
Elisa and it's a contour diagram with
signal to noise so so here's 200
This Is 50 uh this is 20 and this is
this is 10 the outer limit is 10 sign of
10 is is a pretty good is almost around
the threshold for for detection with our
groundbased detectors but you know
different sort of systems but that's the
sensitivity level well you can go out to
in in in the 10 of the five 10 of the
six solar mass range which is where are
the center of our galaxy black hole is
is sitting um you can go out to Red
shifts of 20 with s noise of 5050 or
more with Elisa and and detect
gravitational waves so Elisa will
actually be able to describe and Lisa is
even better Lisa uh these numbers these
sensitivity numbers get bigger and the
and the curve is is broader it goes out
down to here but with these with these
space Bas detectors we will actually be
able to monitor what actually happened
in the early universe as these fragments
are forming and they form their black
holes the black holes merge together and
gradually built up into Central black
holes that we see in the in the galaxies
today that whole story which we only
describe today with computer simulations
um uh Lisa will make visible um and uh
So Lisa is the black hole detection
machine for
astronomy um and of course there's a
region in which we'll have
multimessenger we'll be able to do joint
Lisa Elisa uh joint observations with uh
Optical and other kinds of telescopes
uh all right so I so uh the other thing
was in the center of that region for
local black hole mergers that the signal
noise ratios go over a thousand and so
with that immense noise you can make uh
uh you can investigate black holes in
great detail we can measure the spins
and their directions the masses to
incredible Precision um we can uh
measure the distances we can do the
Hubble constant and so on there there's
a huge amount of work um test her theem
test the cosmic sensorship uh all of uh
all of those things I do want to just
quickly measure the Pulsar timing as as
I said be
before uh uh groups of radio astronomers
they're making progress they pull their
data what ha the idea of Pulsar timing
is that is that neutron stars the
pulsars they're good clocks and so if
you're monitoring six or eight pulsars
around the sky and you're correlating
the arrival times of the pulses all the
time You can predict let's say from five
of them and and study over a period of
time you can predict when the next one
is going to be for the others they their
clocks monitoring each other but a
gravitational wave comes in and distorts
the travel distance of some of those
signals in different ways and so
suddenly it throws all those
correlations out the some of them are
delayed some of them are coming in too
soon and um by by averaging over a long
time over about a year or more you can
get rid of all sorts of noise and and
get down to the level where you can see
these correlations and this is a
gravitational wave passing the Earth
therefore with periods of an order of a
year and that's why it's very large
black holes 10 of the 10 10 of the nine
Sol Mass black holes and um these people
are really really going at it very
intensively now and they're building up
sensitivity and they're not far away
from the first predictions Alberto sazan
at uh the Albert Einstein Institute in
G made a detailed study through the
through the simul ation of G of of
structure formation in the early
universe made a detailed study of what
uh the Pulsar timing people should be
expecting and where they are and this is
a this is an amplitude scale of of
random gravitational waves the
amplitudes is quite large for these
backgrounds as I was saying to you 10us
15 and so on for the cosmological
background this is also for the
astrophysical backgrounds um this is a a
probability distribution and and we he
he he's taken many many different
scenarios uh for for structure formation
and uh with random number generators and
just run them so he's got he's got you
know thousands of model universes and
and he so he can predict in each of the
from from this an ensemble of
predictions of the gravitational wave
intensities and they're all sort of
clustered around here this is where they
are today this is where the observers
are today they're encroaching on the
beginning of
this in about 3 four years they should
be around here and so so we should be
expecting by the end of this decade that
Pulsar timing will produce uh its own
detection of gravitational waves and a
random background of gravitational waves
from these most massive black holes that
have been formed uh and there's now a
race I mean really ligo doesn't want to
be the second in this race ligo is
turning on but it doesn't know if it's
going to be detecting for another two
years depends on the source rates and so
it's very possible that uh the first
detections will be done by the Pulsar
timing people
um okay this is my last slide
uh um what is it uh let me go back sorry
um what is it that um
uh uh motivates uh us a lot besides all
the things that you can predict is the
things you can't so every time a new
windows opened in
astronomy unexpected things happen we
didn't know about x-ray binary systems
until we put x-ray telescopes up and
started looking um uh radio astronomers
were
radio uh telescope Builders were were
astounded at how much was out there in
the radio Universe um so we I would
think that that would happen with
gravitational waves but when is it going
to happen I don't think it typically
should we should expect it to happen
with the first systems which are just
barely sensitive to detect the things we
expect and where we have to do this
matched filtering this we have to know
what the signal is ahead of time before
we can even detected um but by the time
we get to uh High signal noise platforms
like Lisa and and like ET then we should
expect I think uh not just the things we
know about but the things we don't know
about and I just wanted to compare that
um when did a window open these are the
different windows in astronomy when was
it opened galileia opened the optical
astronomy window with the first um
telescopes the first surprise was right
away Jupiter's moons Okay so so he
violated my Criterion that it doesn't
happen the First with the first
instruments uh Galileo uh found
Jupiter's moons and so so the discovery
was was exactly the same time as um uh
the first the window was open cosmic
rays were opened in
192 they finally found something really
surprising which was the detection of
the muon in the 1930s radio telescopes
began to be built in the
1930s they uh uh began the big surprises
were giant radio radio galaxies the
cosmic microwave background and pulsars
and they came in the 50s and 60s not in
the 1930s x-ray observation of the sky
began in
1948 um the big surprises were the first
x-ray binary uh that was 1962 and then
understanding X-Ray binaries when the
first satellite was launched in 1969
again a gap uh gamma rays were first uh
detected in 1961 from space uh Gamay
bursts were actually first detected only
a few years later in in uh uh in the
1960s they weren't actually published
you may know the story that it was
classified information from from US
military they were looking for Gamay
bursts from the Russians for uh from uh
uh uh um nuclear tests and so on um and
uh they had this network of satellites
around around the earth that were
looking down but occasionally they
picked up bursts and when they Tri
angulated with several satellites they
were not coming from the ground they
were coming from somewhere out there and
they thought oh that's throw that away
we're not interested in that but they
did have a few people in the in the
military who said you know that could be
important stuff for other people we
should release this data and the general
said release the data tell the Russians
what we can sense you know what the
sensitivity of our detectives is no
we're not going to do that so it took 10
years or 15 years after the uh first
after the US military knew there were
Gamay bursts coming from outer space
before the rest of us were informed uh
so uh so is that a you know that's the
surprise uh event I hope we don't have
that with gravitational waves I could
tell you I could tell you that some
people have obtained funding from the
military on the grounds of uh using
gravitational waves to detect I don't
know uh submarines and things like that
uh there are some unscrupulous people
who will get money from uh Na generals
um but um
um I I don't think we have any uh any of
that going on now okay so that's time to
I'm sorry I've taken almost two hour and
a half more than an hour and a half but
okay so I think we should invest at
least five minutes of questions yeah
yeah I have a question to the
you show that this interferometry like
as if there were different PA length but
the
micer in in special relativity didn't
show it up this way can one understand
it in terms of
ofed can I answer that question in my
second lecture because the second
lecture is about detection principles
and I address that point
yeah Yes actually my question is about
one of the earliest slide where you
talked about black hole energy flux you
made you made an estimate where like it
was C 5 over G but that's actually the
or that's the order of the plank
Luminosity right yes so I mean how can
we be sure I mean that these are regime
that where we aren't even sure if if our
models should work so well remember just
because it's called plank doesn't mean
it's Quantum there's no h bar in that
formula so all that means is that any
black hole and and there's no m in that
formula so that that formula applies to
any mass of black hole it applies to the
10 the 10 Cellar Mass black holes as
they merge together it applies to a 10
Cellar Mass black hole binary as they
merge together exactly the same
Luminosity Peak Luminosity the
difference in energy that they radiate
is the time scale so 10 to the 10 Cellar
Mass black holes take 10 of the 10 times
longer than a one Cellar M black hole
and so they're radiating that Peak
Luminosity 10 of the times long 10 to 10
times longer and they radiate 10 to the
10 times more energy um but it's
independent of the scale the peak
Luminosity is independent of the scale
and doesn't have an H bar in it so it
goes all the way down to the plunk Mass
black holes but has nothing to do with
quantum
gravity that's true but we now have
numerical simulations that verify it it
it comes out yeah
um you were showing us simulation of the
theer with magnetic fields and I was
wondering in well in this picture we saw
the magnetic fields but they were not
closed yeah so the magnetic fields were
not yeah um yeah it's very it was it was
not a quazer it's a Gamay burst although
the same the same phenomenon May well it
may be similar to what's happening in
quazar but that simulation was PR two
neutron stars the Gamay burst
um uh there are it that's true you you
saw these white magnetic lines going out
that way and you didn't see the ones
looping around it's not a perfect dipole
field it is they are carried away but
what you have to understand also is it's
mhd there is matter in the background
that isn't being shown I just showed you
the gr the magnetic field lines but
there's a lot of matter that's streaming
out and so on so it's not a simple
vacuum magnetic field um and uh the
other thing is that you saw also there
was a there was a a sort of U um stuff
in the in the plane in a different color
that is a that is a toroidal magnetic
field so there's a lot of magnetic field
that's circling around that way that's
also associated with the currents the
mass currents in the um uh the the the
currents carried by the MH masses in the
mhd and that's still circling around the
outside of the black hole so it's a very
complicated situation
uh yeah so let me explain to people who
don't know about dry and wet merges
that's the reason I didn't talk about it
but um um the question is when two two
galaxies merge as often happens and
their black holes are there their black
holes are brought together and there's
kind of friction uh um with the with the
Stellar population as the Stellar
population becomes less distorted and
forms for perhaps an elliptical uh
Galaxy or or something like that the um
uh uh this energy transfer between the
black holes and for and and the black
holes are are gradually brought closer
and closer together um but then what
happens then the question is can they uh
do they get uh very close together and
close enough together to to to merge
together or they just stay as a binary
pair orbiting for forever um and people
have investigated this in two different
scenarios there's the dry scenario which
is just a stellar population just the
interaction with a stellar population
and there's the wet scenario which is
where there's a lot of gas as well as
the as the stars because galaxies do
contain a lot of a lot of gas and the
gas has turbulence and the gas has a
different kind of uh dynamical effect on
the black holes as they move through the
gas and create uh disturb gravitational
disturbances and so on they lose uh
energy so uh so there's wet disturbances
there's wet mergers and there's dry
mergers and the wet mergers tend to be
more effective um I think I think the
the answer uh the the attempt to to
distinguish between wet and dry
um will be a subtle one and it'll depend
on number number of things first it'll
depend upon whe How many um events are
there are we seeing a a larger
population of of these events which
might indicate wet scenarios or dominant
or or smaller than we expect but also
when we get counterparts so the idea is
to is is is to use the Lisa error box on
the sky and find out what galaxy is
actually the Galaxy that um uh uh in
which this merger is taking place and
then then with x-rays and with Optical
observations of that Galaxy you should
be able to tell how much gas is there
was this a um a wet or a dry merger
event itself for each individual event
um we do think it's not unreasonable to
be able to pinpoint the counterpart
galaxies because um uh galaxies in which
em merger has just taken place that
we've detected with gravitational waves
should be highly Disturbed and they
shouldn't look like uh the average
Galaxy and so although there's a a
fairly big error box on the sky that the
astronomers have to look at we think it
shouldn't be um too difficult to to
arrive at an identification of a
counterpart
Galaxy the
questions that's not thee let's